I wish I had actually given me a
I think this script sort of or a stick
or something
um I'm not cheering out of any sort of
you know having any kind of
qualifications to particularly chair
this session but just because Sean asked
me to I take the intention of this
session which i think is officially
called philosophy slash science should
be to discuss what role philosophy can
play for scientists and pushing that
forward and what role science can play
for philosophers in terms of pushing
their agenda forward I'd like to
encourage a real open exchange if we can
have it in the sense of less oppressing
of pre-existing theses you know which
has been interesting over the past
couple of days but really just an
opportunity to see if we can really ask
each other genuine sort of questions
about what we could do really in the
spirit of moving forward you know really
is there something that we can all walk
away and ponder when go back to our
various labs desks in my case couch and
I'm gonna let Massimo introduce really
in terms of content something to give us
to talk about but I think we should feel
free to riff as we like on this issue of
what we can offer each other in terms of
kind of split to different communities
you know science and philosophy what can
we really offer each other and will this
dialogue continue when we leave okay
Massimo right so I have a special
interest I suspect we all have an
interest obviously otherwise we wouldn't
be here in the rush between science and
philosophy I think of my own as perhaps
a little more special than usual simply
because I have this unusual background
having been a practice in scientist and
a prac and now a practicing philosopher
and having actually had gone to school
for both cases and so I can I feel that
I have a maybe not unique but certainly
unusual perspective in I mean actually
in a petitioner in both in both
disciplines and see exactly where each
side comes from where
when when they dismiss or criticize or
make fun of the other so I'm gonna put
up a few slides as a way to introduce
the discussion of course I think that
everything that you're gonna see in the
next few minutes is gonna be very
uncontroversial so we can pack five
minutes after this and go home but I'd
be surprised if that's actually going to
be the outcome so so you know we're
supposed to talk about science
philosophy and by the way that little
thing in the middle scientism whatever
that is so we need to sort of agree on
that one that is um so first of all I'd
say that I suggest that we don't play
semantics games and that when we talk
about science and philosophy we'll talk
about the academic disciplines as
they're practiced so you know science
cannot be taken to be just whatever
deals with facts just like philosophy
cannot be whatever deals with thinking
because otherwise well scientists and
philosophers and we haven't said
anything particularly interesting I
think so just to make more clear what I
mean by that the thing on the upper left
it's a scientific fact or a collection
of scientific facts the fact that I live
nearby the Queensboro Bridge is not a
scientific fact it's just a fact
okay so I take it scientific facts would
be a subset of facts about the world
arrived at by the methods of science and
by the community of science not just
simple observations about how the world
works similarly with philosophy you know
the one up on the upper left is actual
philosophy the one on the lower right
it's not and you know that's ron Hubbard
over there
so again you know we want to make a
distinction it's not like oh I got a
philosophy and and therefore I'm a
philosopher now it doesn't it doesn't
work that way just this morning I got as
a as a part of our Twitter feed that has
been going on for the last few days you
know somebody made the usual predictable
comment that all the philosophy is gone
in so technical and academic that it's
essentially irrelevant to the rest of us
and my response to that is yes true but
that's true for any academic discipline
most of what scientists do is irrelevant
to the rest of us that's the nature of
academia now you can say that that's a
good thing a bad thing or whatever I
think it's inevitable but it's not it's
I don't see why people sort of single
out this one field as opposed to and
then let everybody else pass on that
again so science in my view becomes a
particular type of structural social
activity characterized by empirically
driven hypothesis testing about the way
the world works peer review technical
journals and so on and so forth that's
what I mean by science I don't mean just
getting up on going out of the you know
in downstairs and say oh there is a road
across the street that's a fact but it's
not science similarly I mean the
philosophy is broadly speaking about
deploying logic and general tools of
reasoning an argument to reflect on
broad ranges of subject matters like
epistemology ethics aesthetics and so on
and so forth as well as to reflect on
other disciplines and these are the
philosophies of a lot of philosophy
today is in fact a philosophy of
citizens as philosophy of physics
philosophy of biology this philosophy
chemistry this philosophy language this
philosophy blah blah blah and it's sort
of you can think of that as sort of a
meta reflection on those disciplines and
of course practitioners of those meta
reflections better being formed and
respectful of those disciplines which is
not always the case but those that are
actually making interesting I think
contributions but contributions to what
you might say come up in a second
so another point I think is is to get
readies the philosophy is not in the
business of advancing science and we got
science for that and therefore you know
it doesn't make any sense to me I hear
this accusation over and over you know
what it must be done for us recently
well why do you think the philosophy is
supposed to be doing something for you
it's not it's a different discipline it
has different concerns different methods
different different all sorts of things
now some philosophy is in fact continues
with science and those are the
philosophies of science philosophy
mathematics philosophy physics
there are certain number of papers a
rarely it's small one however in in the
full in the full data philosophy there
is number of papers where if you read
them you really want to be able to tell
whether they've been written by a
scientist or a philosopher or a
mathematician or philosopher in fact
often that written by both there is a
number of philosophers who publish in
mathematics or physics or biology
journals and vice versa a number of
physicists and mathematicians and
biologists who publish in philosophy
journals and those are really at
interface those are about conceptual
clarification of borderline areas
between science and philosophy but that
I think it's a fairly small area it's
not the main concern of philosophy it's
not even the main concern of philosophy
of then the question of how philosophy
makes progress comes up we think we all
have an understanding of how science
makes progress of course there will be
that there are volumes written about
that sort of stuff by philosophers among
other things my social scientists
etcetera but I think we can in this
group we can assume that we know how
science makes progress philosophy I
think makes progress by a very different
route it's really I think of it as an
exploration of logical space so you
start with a certain problem if somebody
comes up with certain number of ideas
then people sort of criticize those
ideas then there is a response to those
criticism and things move and become
more complex and move away occasionally
positions are entirely abandoned like
logical positivism for instance in other
case the debate is not resolved but it
has improved for instance the debate
between scientific realism and
scientific anti-realism in philosophy
science
it hasn't been settled but there have
been novel positions and there surgery
original positions that are not tenable
anymore because of criticism so if I
think that is a way in which one can
make sense of the idea that philosophy
doesn't make progress
let me bring bring up the bad boy of
physics who famously said the philosophy
science is about is useful to scientists
ornithology is to birds I think I agree
now there are different ways of cashing
out that concept the nesting falah a
reply would be well that's because birds
are too stupid to understand ornithology
but i won't go there it's true and
that's because ornithologists are
concerned with different things from
what birds are concerned with so clearly
there is no this very little overlap
there's one area of overlap
interestingly whatever ornithology one
of the consequences of Ornithology of
course is that it provides information
about rare birds and you know things
like I'm about to go extent and so those
birds probably should be concerned with
ornithology I'm not suggesting there is
a direct analogy there obviously between
lots of field science but I do think
that that is the that is the capture
this idea that broadly speaking the two
disciplines are in fact
separate and then there are some areas
of contact
what about scientism well there is much
of definitions out there of scientism I
picked on two that I think I sort of
capture most of the what's going on in
that debate in the strong sense I think
scientism is the view that only
scientific claims or only questions that
can be addressed by science are
meaningful ok so you can think of it as
of the positivist version of in a weaker
sense or somewhat weakens weaker sense
it is the view that methods of the
Natural Sciences can and should be
applied to any subject matter okay I
think the first one is undefensible I
think the second one needs to be
qualified but I'm sure that we'll have
some discussion about ok
it I think the second one it should be
qualified but we can I can get on board
on some version of the second one I
think the first one is it's in fact too
strong for example there's I think there
is a pretty good number of things where
science has little or nothing to say
about I count math and logic in there I
understand that a lot of people think of
Malthus as a science I think that's not
a tenable position because it's a very
different kind of activity it doesn't
depend at all analytical information
about the rest of the world it's very
relevant to science so it's logic but
they're def different disciplines
certain aesthetic ethics and so on its
fourth now aesthetics that should be a
nice there now even in aesthetics and
ethics I don't think the facts are
irrelevant nor do I think that
scientific information of some stuff
that deals with those things is
irrelevant which is why I would accept
the second version the weaker version of
scientists but largely one can do
aesthetics in ethics and logic and math
without any input from science and just
be fine with it anyway yeah of course
there are discoveries we discover
something we don't invent it I'm on
board with that
okay there's something about the
difference between discovery and sort of
analysis and I do see that as a putting
math and logic somewhere in between that
they're not really a subject matter
that's totally separate for science I
mean you can say suppose as a physicist
I have a physical scenario in mind which
forces me or other physicists you know
largely string theorists these days to
make mathematical discoveries so so it
makes it a foggier not just
motivationally but they're saying there
is a physical reality even if it's one I
haven't yet probed experimentally but
I'm you know for thought assuming that
this is going to constrain the kind of
matter I think that me to discoveries
here
I'd like to finish it - calling one one
more two more slides and yeah I think
that's an interesting discussion as
chair of the session I'm allowing people
to interrupt yeah your head it's a good
thing she doesn't have a Taser okay
now the other thing I think we could
agree reasonably on is that yes in
number of philosophers say bizarro
things about science or even about
philosophy itself Neagle and father have
been two examples that have been brought
up recently even in these in these
workship by the same token I think
whether we should also agree that a
pretty good number of scientists say
bizarre things about philosophy or even
about science itself Lawrence Krauss and
Freeman Dyson are very good examples of
Krauss I think embarrassed himself three
times at least this year and days and
just did that last week so there is the
Atlantic interview then there is a
scientific American apology prompted by
Dan which turned out to be nothing but
like an apology and then he did a land
thing exchange in The Guardian with
Julian by genie where where I think he
went even further into doggy
dougies or even further
Dyson roted this review recently of
holds book about no philosophy since
Nietzsche
you know these kind of things are hardly
the stuff of intellectual discussion
that's what I actually read the book and
it's kind of you know it's okay so
Krauss and so I I have to say I'm
outside of that story so I don't know
well Kraus started out with Pacific
typical thing that I actually mentioned
a few minutes ago which is well when was
the last time that that philosophers did
something you know software apps offer
solve a problem I feel problem physics
which I think again it's at the very
least a mistaken idea about what
philosophy is about and then when an in
went on in the impact in particularly in
the in the guardian piece you know
talking about how science is gonna give
us after answers to morality basically
buying into the sam harris thing
wholesale even though he's not even a
biologist so he's not even you know it
in that case he doesn't know what he's
talking about both as in terms of
philosophy anis as science but just in
the spirit of saying we're trying to
bridge the divide i mean as much as I
think Krauss you know his comments were
inflammatory I still don't want to say
things like he's not a philosopher
therefore cannot comment on philosophy
do you know what I mean no I wouldn't
say that to be in a position where
they disagreed with you on the back of
my book not on the back right a little
bit more of the back story Lawrence
Carroll average the social psychologist
makes this great point that if people
agree about 99% of things and disagree
about 1% they will in the course of
natural dialogue they will turn each
other into you know terrible enemies and
I think this is what has happened with
Lawrence and the philosophy community as
a whole he gave some talk that was a
youtube sensation about how modern
physics explains how the universe can
come about sort of in a self-contained
way right without any external designer
and it was sort of you know good red
meat for the atheists and people liked
it and as cosmology it was fine so
naturally he was merged to write a book
about it right and can cash in and so
the book you know and put but then you
know the book title would lead you to
believe that it was telling you why
there is something rather than nothing
all right and yes and Richard Dawkins
says that this is you know up there with
the origin of the species as an
important landmark what I bear boys it's
funny picture but the point was that you
know Lauren wasn't addressing the
question that philosophers take to be
asked when you say why is there
something rather than nothing and so so
then the book was reviewed in the New
York Times by David Albert who as a
philosopher does care about the actual
philosophy question and it was not a
charitable Ricky who in any to say later
the but and David says well it was much
more charitable than all the reviews
they're still on my computer that didn't
get sense to the New York Times and so
then it all went downhill from there yes
actually David came to my apartment
where I had this group of mostly
neuroscience
some physicists to discuss that review
in to tease apart his comms we could
talk about that you know but but you're
right that the I certainly wouldn't go
to the point of saying is with where
Jared we've had this discussion in the
past and I think we clarified ourselves
no there is no territory that cannot be
invaded by or or talked by the other
side if we're talking about intellectual
issues I think any competent intelligent
person ought to be able to talk about it
but that comes with a responsibility so
just like we expect rightly philosophers
to get the science correct when they're
talking about science and we chastise
them if they don't again correctly I
think the same should be going for
scientists yeah yeah well yes okay so
anyway that would those were just
examples my general idea in all of this
is is I guess I'm a little bit of old
fashioned from that perspective because
I think actually that this whole thing
ought to be too looked at as from the
point of view of what used to be called
San Thea which is a Latin word for
knowledge in the broader sense see
Anthea there was actually a journal
called Cynthia when I was an
undergraduate and then it unfortunately
closed down that's right there's no more
knowledge in the broad sense which
exactly there's only Technic and in
knowledge in the broad sense there
includes science for sure philosophy
mathematics and logic that was sort of
the broader realm of and these things
are not seen as completely separate
fields are seen lies largely looking at
different things in different ways but
they're sort of supposed to interact
with each other into giving us give us
sort of knowledge in the broad sense it
was fun thank you now I also think that
that knowledge is more narrow concept
than understanding and human beings seek
understanding not just knowledge and I'm
trying to run into a distinction here
that will bring therefore in things like
music literature and the broader
humanities because those I think as
Rebecca was saying just yesterday are
necessary for an understanding because
we're human beings we think in a certain
way we don't we don't just think in
terms of equations we don't just think
in terms of logic well we understand
things in a broad you know using a broad
swath of approaches which include those
things I'm not saying that therefore we
should be doing you know novel novelized
version of quantum physics but I'm
saying that it's we're talking about
scientism as well this is the only way
to know and to understand things that's
not gonna hold and finally let me remind
you this quote by Isaac Asimov and
intellectualism it's been a constant
winding thread winding its way through
our political and cultural life nurtured
by the false notion that democracy means
that my ignorance is just as good as
your knowledge I mean this is our common
enemy in the United States there's a
very good tradition sociology of
actually tracking in different types of
anti-intellectualism the United States I
think we're all concerned with these
kind of things and I think we don't do
any any good surface to the cause of
fighting anti intellectual is when we
start finding about your stuff is
nonsense that one is idiotic and so on
and so forth in fact I will go as far as
saying that any broad claim like that is
itself anti intellectual and feeds into
these sort of things that that is
problematic in American society so
that's it that's that's what I wanted to
say thanks I'm sure people have comments
but I actually wanted hopefully to ask
David I know David dear over there are
you paying attention to us could
somebody hit David I heard really like
to ask David because cos David said you
know I think unique here possibly being
well this isn't totally fair but the
most experimentally oriented would that
be fair to say and so I think you have
you know a unique perspective whereas
the theorists really sometimes have to
just think it's completely at a meta
level
about their work I think you know you
have a different perspective rentals
don't think yeah because David thinking
equals philosophy and what you do is
science but I mean I like I think my
CMOS and presentation is very helpful
goes right to the heart of the matter
for me it was so I learned a lot and
it's been extremely valuable but what I
had hoped to learn as it or take away as
an experimentalist is more about the
putative continuity I think you had
Massimo and your prisoner at the
continuity between let's say philosophy
of science or philosophy of mind and the
things that I have to worry about the
lab scientists and that this seems to me
completely elusive at the moment so I
had hoped in the context of a discussion
but naturalism to really find let's say
conceptual alignments somehow between
the concerns we have in the bench or
whatever you like to call that and the
concerns you have and I didn't feel that
at all is it's not clear to me what I'm
supposed to take away as a practitioner
that changes how I do my business in
terms of you know experimental design
first I said what types of questions am
I supposed to address in which way to
deal with the challenges of naturalistic
inquiry so has that chance
it has regrettably not changed my mind
about how you know what kinds of
questions I can address how to address
them and that's that's what what I
wanted I guess I wanted a closer more
specific alingment its curiosity driven
how can we put our heads together and
figure out how your philosophical
concerns can merge with what we can
actually accomplish to come up with kind
of mechanistic causal stories about how
stuff works and and that's not yet there
and that's that would be my earning as
it were here's one one suggestion that's
pretty close to you actually
the bunch of experiments that were
mentioned and never carefully described
were been libbets
work and then soon at all there's a
whole lot of it and some of us believe
that those experiments are badly done in
the first place
at least livets were and what the
scientists said about them we're
extremely naive theoretically and that
there's now the problem that a lot of
non scientists hear these proclamations
by scientists not by philosophers about
the implications of this work and that
our that our ill-founded and it seems to
me here is an area where where where
experimental scientists if they think
they've found something that is of shall
we say philosophical importance and they
may I certainly make there a lot of
experiments that really undo traditional
philosophical ideas are important well
that's been my stock and trade over the
years really is pointing these
experiments out and sort of rubbing
philosophers noses and some of them but
I don't think those experie I don't
think the limit experiments are our
cases in point but very but then there
is a question about what should the
experimental scientists do when they
think they've uncovered something of of
more than interest just to their
particular experimental discipline but
they think it has a sort of
earth-shaking results
that's funny example I wish I could say
my artwork it's been for my philosophy
is Phil kitcheners analysis of
evolutionary psychology
I think philosophers have the tools to
be able to see the analogical tools to
be able to see whether a conclusion
follows from certain assumptions that
scientists aren't trained to do so the
way I think about the evolution of human
behavior has been changed by these
philosophical ruminations of course
that's only because phil is deeply
equated with evolutionary psychology
that he was able to do that but I think
there's some a set of ways of thinking
about things that scientists can benefit
from and things really in our courses
we're supposed to do experimental
research maybe it's even good maybe it's
like libbets experiments not so good you
surely internally criticize those
experiments anyway anyway anyway so but
now the burden is is say well we think
it has interesting interpretation so
where I'm supposed to come running and
say wait sort of the logical good no Dan
Dan posed the question what should they
do that was verbatim your question and
and so you're repeating about what
should we do in your estimation yeah
to laboratory work and naturalism as a
philosophical movement shares probably
universally its obligation to let what
you tell us the facts are lead
philosophical and the theoretical
discussion with the critical proviso
that of course we have to examine what
though what what the descriptions of the
laboratory results are but I'd like a
stronger burden I'd like you guys to
take us time into IIIi would like to
adopt the rich and you know well reason
to philosophical additions and form it
decide young you are a mental agenda on
the basis of where your curiosity drives
you not on the basis of some extraneous
philosophical theory what I'm sorry just
just pick what Alex um what we do you
know I mean experiments the sizes too
often test a theory
sure and so in some sense may be David's
asking are you promoting any theories I
can test in the lab would that be one
way of phrasing it are you saying in a
sense that you realize that's trying to
translate down you know a larger scale
position into you know am i measuring
this or that and my in my dishes and
that but I mean I guess it would be nice
to find sort of the cone of direction of
argumentation or the kind of data that
were for instance helping that's not so
I think
not the data that generated so the the I
mean it would be helpful to look let's
take the discussion yesterday afternoon
which was a little weird about meaning I
mean there's lots of stuff we know I
mean there's a you know a great work in
cognitive psychology psycholinguistics
linguistic theory from the last 50 years
a we can draw on that there's actually
pretty detailed and we can test that
stuff
now there's disagreements in this room
about whether that's important or not
that would be useful to know about is
this kind of position worth testing is
this kind of position worth testing in
the way I then develop the experimental
details in a quarter of the day so there
I think that alignment can be more
closed than they have seemed to me at
the moment in terms of to my mind
philosophy done in the right way that is
not as conceptual analysis I'll say in a
minute what I think it how I think of it
instead but philosophy done in the right
way and good science are absolutely
continuous I mean I don't feel myself to
be crossing any kind of boundary when I
go from one to the other the the the key
problem is to is to do both throughout
what there are ways of doing both
science and philosophy that will create
a gap and so on the one hand though I
regard philosophy of science as
basically normative normatively critical
history of science really understanding
why science what why the sequences of
hypotheses and and the particular
directions in which implications were
drawn from scientific work went in the
direction they did with some assessment
of you know the normative aspect as well
which things were called the sacks which
things were circular errors which things
were in what were the best instances of
real progress so that we can apply those
things to current practice economists
tend not to know very much about their
own history and if they do if they think
they know something about their own
history it's usually myth right so good
creative
of history of economics I think
crucially informs good economics I can
give an example probably you know what
what aspect of economics has made the
most noise in popular in the popular
mind over the last five or ten to add to
ten years well a bunch of reports from
behavioral economics in a certain so the
style of neuro economics that I think is
largely philosophical bollocks right and
to see that it is bollocks you have to
you have to recognize to think you're to
both you both have to look have an
experimental program that you can
explain is different from that bollocks
program but you also have to have you
can't just announce as I'm doing right
now you can't just call it names you
also have to have a story you have to
understand how in light of the critical
history of the discipline the there's
something wrong with this simplistic
behavioral economics program and
something better that you can do instead
so I wind up then often criticizing
economist from what I take to be a
philosophical point of view but I also
criticize the philosophers who talk
about economics largely in ignorance of
the technical details economics is an
intensely technical subject and if and
and many philosophers talk about it
without really understanding that so and
I think similar remarks been made about
physics and biology and the whole gamut
so I don't think that anything special
about economics in this I was just going
to respond in the sense that there was a
conversation that keeps coming up over
lunch obviously especially among the
physicists that there is a role for
philosophy of science that's actually
right there deep in the physics
sometimes and and and that would be for
instance and they Simon's talked about
this and Sean and Stephen and I talked
about this in things like the
interpretation of quantum mechanics
where physicists really don't have a
handle on what's going on right we can
operationally do what we do with
equations it's fantastically tested
paradigm but it's not one that we
actually in any forward-thinking sense
understand right
as the academic discipline of the
philosophy of science actually advanced
they came from Cass or has it been less
ideal their employment counseling both
but I think people like David Albert who
called themselves philosophers of
science who also you know he does have a
physics degree and all that but it is
very much on that cusp I think that some
sense Don is describing an economics and
philosophy that people are very much on
that cusp is pressing people to think
harder but what do you mean by the
collapse of the wavefunction what do you
mean by the many-worlds interpretation
and if we keep scratching at this one
area where we clearly have a massive gap
in our comprehension maybe we'll make an
actual real-life physical discovery and
I think that's a genuine place yes we
have very clear examples where
philosophy of physics has helped physics
and it may continue in things like the
landscape them oh we won't go into it
all now but in that sense it's a little
maybe closer to David's you know hope
and that it it it gives people who are
on that cusp of trying to understand
fundamental physics some tools and
changes the goal poem as a gold positive
almost everyone the highest level of
evolutionary biology recognizes the name
because some mere upper levels of
selection problem and the relevance of
prices equation to this debate in a way
that at any rate I've heard scientists
on BBC say well we're not going to solve
this problem we have to leave it to soon
okay I know oh and wants to say
something but also not to unfairly
demand that the scientists have a right
to tell the Philosopher's what they
ought to be right we don't have to say
look this would be better for us you'd
better give us what we need right you
obviously have your own programs as I
think Massimo laid out but Owen III was
just gonna I was a little bit worried
because I know time is short that our
our discussion you would yet again be
too abstract in general I I think that
in answer to David's question like
here's one thing that's just struck me
in its I have no horses in this race
although I'm really interested in as an
outsider so take there's a history of
caen so here's here's a way I think we
make progress the Devils in the details
the history of reflection on the nature
of time so we know for example that the
physicists in the room have to think
about time and we know that there are
controversies in physics about the
nature of time then there's a lot of
work in psychology about you know
classical work on phenomenology of time
barracks long and people like that and
then there's the kind of work that David
talked about yesterday where we get this
sort of data that shows that the brain
doesn't care about time at a certain
level of granularity I think having
people sit down who have particular
content full perspectives to bring on a
problem and then have them talk about
how because a lot of that the Alex
mentioned the other day ed Wilson's you
know concept of Concilium
you know or you know there's ideas of
unification or reduction or Concilium
and this is just an interesting topic I
think and as soon as David spoke about
that I thought boy I had heard about his
work on this but I think that's really
interesting know again I don't work on
it so I'm never gonna write it up but
the point is those kind of discussions
it goes back to what massimo talked
about you know the division of
intellectual labor is such that
sometimes you don't meet people who do
things that are that interesting until
you come into a room like that
and know the information was there to be
had yeah so I guess one way to put what
I just says I don't think there's any
general answer to the question of what's
the intellectual division of labor and
how should it work I think there's you
know the fact that Alex says everybody
knows Samira kosha and the most
distinguished evolutionary biologist in
the room doesn't know Samira the kind of
contribution denicio seeks book is made
the kind of contribution that both
biologists and philosophers ought to
read for the next 20 years they're
probably all of us here don't look very
kindly on philosophers who have made a
huge thing over the hard problem of
consciousness however by concentrating
so much on consciousness and what would
what would be required for an
explanation of consciousness the kind of
thing we were talking about in the first
lecture you know and in Talmud you
require a Talmud we know or something
less I think that the area of cognitive
science is is just a happy hunting
ground for philosophy for a very simple
reason they haven't figured out exactly
what questions to ask yet and there have
been a lot of interesting false starts
and and I mean just just look at the
history of psychology look I mean look
at look at look at the the brave tries
this is the skin areas and the gestalt
psychologists and introspection Ascenta
and we've had wave after wave of
enthusiasm and almost certainly there's
none of this is stupid there's always
Madonna
important contribution to be made but
it's not been anybody's specialty within
the science to sort that out from a sort
of a bird's eye view and talk about well
what in the end does a skineri and
psychology offer after we subtract all
the confusions visit through a message
error I'm one who said yes three years
right people came around to a lot of
that and similarly for them sort of
every every enthusiasm we've had complex
dynamical systems right now the current
hot topic and I think for very good
reasons is predictive coding and
Bayesian approaches to modeling in the
brain these are very tempting very
tempting perspectives and so very smart
people succumb quite properly to the
temptation and throw themselves on to
one bandwagon or another and then
there's a merry chase now that's very
different I think from what happens in
physics I don't think there's anything
quite in that in those areas I think I
think there's a I think there's a
there's of course this is me speaking I
find sort of leftover Cartesian
assumptions everywhere people that just
somehow can't rid themselves of the idea
there's a place in the brain where I am
and where everything comes in and that's
where the consciousness happens that's
the Cartesian theater as I call it and
if I could it as wobbly as that your
average kind of the sensor
and I'm but then but then so there's bad
science I mean you know that's there's a
lot of no not it but there are quite a
lot of the questions that are on our
board are actually you know addressed by
you know sometimes even proper you know
not bad cognizance how do you make a
moral judgment what does it mean to make
a decision you know is it free and some
you know operational as sense so you
know is there conscious experience what
does it mean to recognize a word and its
meaning that's those are those improper
questions no those are seem to me the
questions at the very much at the center
of what we're trying to figure out and
those don't seem to be M Robert I think
there's a take the Newark and I'm
excused from which I agree that this you
know a lot that's just kind of bollocks
to use here and I don't think I needed
to come to philosophy to realize that I
can take those experience are pretty
well myself not being analyzed but
there's shitty experiments with you know
false assumptions and techniques and
there's also a but there's also a less
well known the good kind of neuro there
is that's right but do we does that
require an interaction between the
sciences and philosophy or experiment to
come to doesn't follow that wire but it
doesn't mean doesn't help either right
mine we can get ideas from whatever they
come from I'd like to make a small
comment about actual practice again I I
think I feel that I don't have an
interesting perspective from that one of
you because I've done both we were
talking and you know some of the
discussions we are gone about well do
philosopher I mean do science really any
philosophers to come up with these this
view of broader view of whatever
sometimes yes sometimes no let's not
forget that the practice is in fact very
different when I was a scientist
especially in the last ten years most of
my time was spent writing damn grant
proposals okay because the funding rate
at NSF is 5% at this point so so it was
right so it's oh it's ridiculous now
what that means is you know you put that
one on top of course that you're
teaching your duties and your graduate
students which and the interaction with
migrations was much more intense as a
scientist and as a philosophy and as a
philosopher you know what I do with my
graduate students I'll see you the next
Thursday at a wine bar and we'll chat
for a couple of hours and that's about
it
as a scientist every day you're in the
lab every day you have to solve
practical problems there is field work
to be done there is data analysis it's a
bunch of stuff which does not afford
most scientists until they until they
take a sabbatical or until they get you
know close to retirement and start doing
philosophy as Gerry actually once
pointed out during a seminar at Stony
Brook when I was there you just don't
have the luxury of stepping back and
taking a broad look at a large amount of
literature in you know in different
fields and say oh let me see what I
think about it the Philosopher's if they
do their job right which clearly it's
not always the case had that like it's
not the luxury that's that's what they
do they don't have to write grant
proposals mostly they don't have
laboratories mostly they don't have
graduate students that pastured them
every day they do have usually more
teaching but whatever so so the
intellectual division of labor is not
just intellectual it's practical it's a
matter of you know there is only so many
hours in the day and there's only so
many things you can do and so why not
take advantage enough David that doesn't
mean again that you what couldn't I
figure out that that one is a bad idea
yes of course you can but there may be
other things you didn't pay attention or
you're not thinking about because you
got busy doing other stuff and so if
somebody comes in from the outside and
says hey have you noticed that okay Don
and then Sean I'm conscious of the fact
that keep skipping shop you ain't good
Thanks doing good good reflection on the
relationship between philosophy and
science is actually quite hard right
because there's a lot of as with
anything else there's quite a lot of
such reflection that isn't very good and
and also I think when different stories
apply in different cases so let me give
one example of what I mean by just bad
stuff on both sides economists have a
tendency to use as rhetoric when they're
arguing with each other the claim that
some behavior that somebody else's model
would require an economic agent to
display isn't rational and they use this
word rationality it's usually largely
empty rhetoric because they mean
different things are meant by it from
one occasion to the next and relatively
few economists have really thought very
carefully but what they want to mean by
that but then on the other side
philosophers will approach to have a
tendency for lawsuits of economics have
a tendency to approach that issue by
doing conceptual analysis of rationality
as if there is a thing rationality
should be and day the philosophers will
discover it that's awesome
no one sits right what what what it what
week what what I think the actual
crucial role that needs to be played and
it needs to be can only be played by
somebody who's who's pretty well versed
in this that kind of normatively
critical history that I'm talking about
which i think is what philosophy is and
but also understands the apathy
constraints on applying things things in
real world in empirical work what you
need to do instead is is is is not
trying to identify what rationality is
but simply be very very clear on how
different ideas about rationality have
played actual roles in the history of
the best work that has actually made
progress in understanding so that you
can then come back into the current
debates and say alright here's something
that is not merely empty rhetoric that
you could say instead I just thought it
might be useful to flesh out the example
of the interpretation of quantum
mechanics as a place where philosophers
have been useful
and and in thinking about it since I
didn't since I had to think the last
five minutes also a place for
philosophers sort of dropped the ball a
little bit because they could have been
useful earlier right and it's clear why
the different communities play different
roles because the scientists very often
and for very good reasons
want to figure out what happens and then
later will figure out what it means
right and so in quantum mechanics is a
great example where we had this this
half-baked formalism of the Copenhagen
interpretation and then you know there's
a classical world that observes the
quantum world and that was good enough
for many many years for really
describing the experiments and people
point out that it wasn't really good
enough because it made no sense but it
still was okay and it's only in recent
last couple decades that there's been a
lot more discussion about that and
partly it was the Philosopher's pressing
on it in part but a crucial role was
actually played by physics because our
experiments are able to probe at what
used to be the inaccessible boundary of
the quantum and classical so we could
make an anti philosophical argument that
you know back in the 1930s the
philosophers could have really just
insisted that this was making no sense
and try to do better but now that we
need to do better because the
experiments are pushing us that way the
philosophers have been very very useful
in explaining mistakes that you know the
scientists have been tempted into so
there's the many-worlds interpretation
which just says the wave function
evolves and it splits into different
worlds and there are bad objections to
that which the philosophers have that
objection
there are also better parry yeah but
there are bad objections like there's
too many universes and objection right
exactly
but then there are also again since the
scientists want to say well I want to
figure out what works and then we'll get
to the details later
you know the idea of deriving the
probability rule the fact that the
probability of getting a result is the
wave function squared a lot of
physicists would just say well let's
just add that on to the effort
interpretation of quantum mechanics to
the many rule let's write it down as a
postulate
and it is the philosophers who have been
saying you know you can't do that it
doesn't make logical sense it's against
the other it's not quite it doesn't fit
in with the other rules and in fact
they're the ones who press on the need
to understand what's going on because on
the one hand the many-worlds
interpretation doesn't have
probabilities in it anywhere and some of
the scientists who who think they're
doing the you know the hard work of
deriving the probability rule from the
many-worlds interpretation what they're
really saying is if there is a rule for
probabilities it must be this one and
put that and that's kind of the easy
part and the hard part is explaining why
it's a theory of probability at all and
that's exactly in the philosophers
wheelhouse to sort of you know address
that question in a deep way now you
might at the end of the day say okay and
if this philosophical nudge moves us to
a better understanding of quantum
mechanics I don't care because I still
know how to calculate things in quantum
mechanics but I think that if it if it
does it sort of immediately gets
absorbed into what we consider the
useful physics research program you know
what kinds of experiments teach us
something when we have entangled quantum
states very very is ever making that
assertion yes I am I'm making the
assertion that we understand more about
the universe now than we did before
without the presence of academic
Foster's in physics so I can quite
understand that sentence I mean you say
that didn't really matter to you whether
the progress of science was had where
the signs have progressed more or
because of the ludic operations of
academic laws I'm saying that young and
philosophers missed a chance in the
earlier years of the 20th century to
have a big impact on the development of
quantum mechanics but now they are
having a big impact on the development
of quantum mechanics and I think too big
will
you know it depends it's when he offered
no no they didn't you know they didn't
listen to John exactly right yeah John
Bellamy great donors they need a 40 or I
okay good you know they could have just
done it I mean the oh it wasn't a matter
of needing new data right you know we
knew enough to come up with a federal
education is a good point until you
really get your foot stuck in a trap you
might not turn to help so I want you to
point out something I don't know if it's
so much about philosophers and
scientists but philosophy and science
and that is that um philosophy is damn
hard to do and it's particularly hard
we all have philosophical intuitions I
was very you know impressed with your
saying something which i think is true
about cognitive science just deep down
they're relying on Cartesian dualism
it's a very flossy something that most
of us don't want to think about even
philosophers right you've got your
intuitions and until you really run into
trouble with them you know they're just
buried down there and they're
percolating up and they're there um and
scientists this is very true for as well
in fact that conversation I had that for
me
pivotal conversation with any working
investor when I was an undergraduate
when he convinced me to go into
philosophy of science rather than a
philosophy and he said you know a rather
than physics connecting the Brickman in
the word yeah but what he said was you
know um scientists are a capitalist
right it works and they just keep going
and you know philosophers are communists
I mean they're constantly rethinking the
basic system and they're keeping it you
know the questions are always on the
people there and do you wanna you know
do you want do you want to be a capital
circus then this was the 1970s and my
answer was clear go ahead but um the
thing is that bad philosophy creeps in
to physics all the time in the case that
I particularly think I was one that you
really Boltzmann right I mean that he
presents a fantastic you know
solution to the arrow of time and nobody
buys it because they're all they
compared philosophy the whole scientific
community has bad philosophy and so it
you know it's really the role of
philosophers to just keep these
questions this is an open question and
to just keep pushing this that these
questions are are open and that it does
affect a can affect and in pivotal times
of the history of science it has little
Oscars I think just have to be used to
the fact that until they find their foot
trapped they're gonna be very rude about
our attempts to move in and say wait a
minute wait a minute I don't think
you're clear about this I mean I think
what's the same thing happened with
consciousness after 1990 suddenly
everybody's writing a book about
consciousness and Crick and DiMaggio and
lean us and and and Christoph Carson
everybody's got to have their book on
consciousness and they try to write
these books and then they think oh this
is hard and and they stumble around and
you know most of those books are pretty
bad and the good thing that's come out
of that for us philosophers is that
there's a lot of much more modest people
in cognitive science and neuroscience
now than they used to be because they've
kind of realized that they do not have a
on how to talk about consciousness and
just to pile on that side of the
argument it when philosophers do make a
very helpful intervention and set things
straight a little bit the reaction of
the scientists will be oh yes I get it
now and then that's obvious I knew that
all along right and they don't ever
remember they do that to each other my
hope is that one day somebody says
that's obvious because that means I
penetrated great like half you're gonna
think this is trivial
you're gonna think it's complete
nonsense yeah I'm just trying to move
people from the nonsense through the
tributing I just want to you know play
it diplomatic go for a second and say
that sometimes the rudeness in fairness
is coming from very vocal very prominent
few and actually I think most scientists
feel very humbled by their field
honestly and and and are more respectful
of people I agree with about a hundred
sentient not not even philosophers want
to talk about for us think about fluffs
we have time cuz it's so hard I mean I
am very aware that sometimes in my own
work I'll rub into something which is
getting into that issue and I just I
want to go calculate because it's so
much more pleasant I know I'm gonna get
somewhere in the Edit cycle washing
dishes I know it's gonna be done you
know and um and so I think that most
centers are more receptive maybe though
less vocal I just want to be a diplomat
for a second I think Jerry had something
and I want to get to this side of the
table to like Simon and Terry who who
have a foot very much in in both field I
was just wanting to say it word for
science maybe I'm just being overly
sensitive but what I sensor is an
attempt of everybody tell philosophy
when philosophers have great there and
no attempt to do anything but dis
scientists I mean this is maybe an
exaggeration for we're not doing the
experiments right by doing Lebed
experiment right for not doing
understanding cutting the research
properly and for writing books about
consciousness which you're bad and yet
this I mean maybe this is implicit in
the whole conference that science has
done good stuff without you know what I
mean what what this to me the whole
conference has been has been a
philosophically dominating
to philosophy and how great it is and I
just wanted to speak up
oh yeah I know I was worried somebody
wouldn't be contentious 90 some percent
of science doesn't show any more
philosophy I can get almost
uncontroversial and so I tried to get my
little you know an example of a case
where the philosophers clearly dropped
the ball and could have done their yeah
so I really would have been ortus anyway
but still a case where really some
compelling mechanistic explanation of
some phenomena was generated because of
an intervention by philosophy which
whichever field biology physical where
that really changes the game mountain
count Einstein's description of special
relativity in the role of liveness and
Barkley and Hearns MA in his thinking
it's pretty good if I'm right about
quantum mechanics it will be with him
okay I think there are those of you
there are mainstream examples you you
can't in cosmology come up with a theory
which puts human beings as special
without getting a lot of flack for that
I mean this is you know clearly a
massive shift starting with Copernicus
and onward where it's just you know it's
it's it's it's a philosophy that human
beings should not be special and it's
mainstream and it's you know may or may
not be very deep but it clearly it's not
acceptable anymore
and to the point where we're string
theorists and cosmologists are arguing
very hard about things like the
landscape the possibility that there's
multiple universes that that the only
reason why the universe looks this way
just happens to be because we're here
asking about either these sort of
anthropic principles and they are
debated heavily among the hard-core
string theorists scientists and whether
it's a it's an acceptable program to
pursue or it's a week program to pursue
the anthropic one for just for example
yeah absolutely absolutely and I think
you know and I think being expected to
be good at that is a fair you know
criterion just like you're expected to
be good at your experiment is a fair you
know
level at which we should have hold our
work
I think Owen where you making sounds
Terry were you making sounds sounds
speech speech like sounds that resembled
English I'm gonna come back to you I'm
gonna make you say Institute when I
teach I need I need read philosophy
quite a bit and just because making
connections between two disciplines
being able to kind of analyze I'm like I
wouldn't necessary can central analysis
but I was just thinking here right so
some fields this is not bad sciences of
really good graduate students who come
and they don't they can't see the
difference between a simulation and a
theory right and this is not something
that physicists have had trouble with
because we've had a right so this is and
I mean in physics right so writing
simulating the thing is not as high
status as making a theory of it but so
we have that kind of already there like
all experiment a numeric or a spirit but
so that that was one huge thing right
and I I didn't realize that this head
you had to make a case for this you had
to be able to distinguish this but if
you can't you can't communicate you you
can't transfer the methods of one
discipline over to the other if you
can't quite line up the you know it's
like the USB ports out with a lot of
different sizes and the other one that
came up with was causation so every
field has a totally unanalyzed notion of
causation and if you don't realize that
causation is normative fundamentally
normative and you don't know what
normativity his or at least just have
some folk account because you Reds
occasional books about it so so I I can
i I can program a computer to find
correlation right I have lots of
mathematical tools to find correlation
if I want to find causation I have to
have a notion of intervention right so
many of us work with you who to pearls
notion of causation which is
fundamentally about what's an
intervention right an intervention in
a neural experiment is not going to look
like an intervention in us in a social
system those kinds of notions are I put
this way they look unscientific to me
right the do operator is not an operator
so the invention is that's the landmark
for normativity that's what you say
that's just yes that's fine yeah why
that's Norman is what we're wondering
about okay that's how interesting this
is
you were Simon talking about how
important reading in philosophy is I'm
thinking about our own families and then
we there's I mean that's very helpful
that there's this confusion but now the
Fosters are saying so it's not normative
so well let me do me to fish quickly so
that that notion of the do operate just
doesn't seem scientific to me but I want
a thought through public account with
smart people who are behaving well and
to tell me how I can use it now I can
resolve difficulties with that
particular do operator and my guess is
is that the philosophers of the people
best equipped to help me do that I might
be wrong I might be that there's some
you know that the debates about norms of
explanation for example they're not
gonna help me with that that might be
the case I mean maybe this is you know
to follow Rebecca's instinct a nice
moment to have like a five-minute you
know leave with the philosophers helping
us out with notions of causation and
normative in this context I mean when
I'm looking constant mental causation
they don't like that that's where I
first thought a long time ago it doesn't
seem to connect to proving whether X
cause why and those kinds of things
and I don't know I would but I would
love to have a five minute seminar
anybody wanna give us a causal
explanation standard but now they can
get error parts so when I get five
opinions that exchange right there it's
typical it's like you know philosophers
often say things like in scientists
point immediately jump on this thing oh
well we're not gonna get one answer
because you know the joke is you got ten
philosophers in the room you get 11
opinions no it's not
you get constraints on those answers you
may get two or three viable answers but
they're not it's not anything goes it's
like anybody's opinion this goes out no
no I know I'm sorry
I didn't mean to imply that you said
that but it this kind of exchange it's
actually represented of what I hear
outside of this room and I think we
should put a stop to it and then qualify
usually brings in a notion
of evaluation right Oh
true/false it's got Autzen exactly so
it's not you know it's um there's some
kind of evaluation that is implied
what's a nice I mean Steve Weinberger
say you ought not to do this is this an
explanation so we I'm sorry wait so when
you said when you were talking about
causality and I thought maybe you
actually meant explanation because you
were using the term normative so the
notion of explanation is implicitly
normative because you know what counts
as a good explanation is is a implicitly
normative concept right because you know
we have all we have many many
explanations we can always as point
taught us we can always generate more
explanations given the data how do we
sort them out it's a sorting you know
there's a kind of sorting mechanism it's
not causation at the level of billiards
there's two big sort of families of
normative ideas and philosophy of
varying we spelled out what I call
Pittsburgh normativity is very much
about ethics and the other notion of
normativity is just about good and bad
but you know good ham or bad hammer
that's that's a value judgment too but
it's it's more about functionality and
the way the way I just think we said
this I say if you want to remember the
difference between them think about the
negative case it's the difference
between being naughty and stupid if
you're if you're if you fail to meet the
Pittsburgh norm you're naughty
if you fail to meet the functional norm
you're stupid
your nature takes care of extinguishing
the things that fail to meet the second
barrier arm and society tries to
extinguish the things
fail to make the first [ __ ]
opportunity you need is the kind
warranted a video that says if you have
a Philips screw and you want to stick it
in a piece of wood use it you ought to
use a Philips screwdriver
don't you want not to use a flathead
screwdriver that's the kind of normative
is get exam something relevant to your
there's a little bit but to a certain
extent it's like if you if you want to
do the kinds of things we do and maybe
maybe I'm just repeating this in a more
a perfectly if you want to do the kinds
of things we do in sociology this is the
kind of intervention that counts when
you build the mathematics around your
causal analysis and if you want to do
the kinds of things you do in psychology
even if it's the same system right you
should do it you should imagine a
different kind of intervention do you
have a good example of that because I
see what you're saying but I'm not
convinced that the really are cases like
that that are good that is to say I'd
like to see a case where where the the
sociologists are in effect right to have
a different norm for intervention than
the psychologists would use in the same
circumstance so then I can give you a
toy philosophical sort of philosophical
sounding one that I wouldn't never do
but so someone goes to bar gets drunk
drives home kills somebody on the road
what caused that right so if your
sociologists you might ask questions
about the larger social system right
depending on your notion of history you
might say you know I'm gonna find a look
at this from social practices to go all
the way back so my intervention would be
you know 100 years ago that would be the
de Collins
these you know if I was I throw my
psychologist I will I'll take a
different set of causal pathways right
is this there it seems obvious that
every every different set of field goals
or have different intervention
this at the beginning of art this is a
point that's a point well established in
the Boston history in the philosophy of
law back in the 1930s that different
perspectives will need you to identify
different among the causally necessary
conditions as if they'll cause mm-hmm
and it's silly to argue which of them is
right when all of them are causally
necessary jointly sufficient and
depending on the interests of the
Inquirer one or another will be more
salient doesn't that make the question
of causality as people ask for solutions
to cut me when it when a scientist as
perk up doesn't that make it normative
that's that makes the question of causal
explanation pointed especially through
the through the lenses of judea pearl
when you're looking at through through a
pearl
lens at causation you have choices about
what to consider as the intervention and
both choices are very dependent on what
sort of inquiry you're doing because of
just the points that you made and and so
there are normative questions because
you may say to yourself or your
colleague look you fool you're you're
making the wrong intervention given your
purposes given what you want to figure
out you're not you're not asking the
right interventionist questions
that's normative I suppose some nations
might be true and this is and I mean
this fits right in with what Alex
Alice's example of the of the Phillips
screwdriver
you know if you're and to really take
your own case there is now I think ill
an ill
constructive debate going on about
whether we should turn away from looking
at you know culprits at agents that have
done evil because when we ask questions
about them and whether they could have
done otherwise and so forth we're asking
the wrong the more serious causal
questions we should be asking you about
social illogical conditions and economic
conditions and so forth and our
attention the attention we spend looking
at the the culprit the accused are
distracting us from better causal
inquiries now I as I say I don't think
that's a well a well-formed discussion I
think it's it's ill motivated but you
feel it shouldn't be better formed or
you just take it so you were about to
say it so motivated I cut you off sorry
so you're answering my question
you think it's ill motivated and not
that it should be formulated better I
think there are questions in the
neighborhood that are very good and it
should be asked and we certainly should
get at the the social causes of
criminality let us say for example but I
think the idea that we shouldn't also
ask questions about whether this
particular individual could have done
otherwise it's just mistaken I think you
do both and they say that's crazy this
integral xdx doesn't depend on my my
goals and needs there's a there's a
strict answer and also it's not a matter
of taste or preference for different
kinds of explanations whether or not you
use the shannon form of entropy it has
the correct properties that's the one
you've got to use no debate and then all
of a sudden halfway through your lecture
somebody raises their hand and asks one
of these questions that gets you into a
question about I guess the normativity
of explanation and if you start giving
them a fuzzy answer they might say well
this
in science your Remora and if you and if
you can't give a solid account as you
guys have been giving they're either
going to walk out or they're gonna not
change their discipline or you're not
gonna be able to communicate and so
that's a huge this is really value I
think actually that goes back to David
you can help the scientists or can it
you know ask questions may be enough
design experiments but I think this sort
of simple-minded answer is that
philosophy helped us decide whose easy
questions are interesting right that's
one the other one is more to the that
would help we should be so lucky
the other ones to give it an interesting
account of what counts as an explanation
that would actually really help right so
I have my own pre theoretical intuitive
sense of what I think a causal
mechanistic explanation is in my world
and I kind of make it up as a but I
think it's you know I try to convince
myself that it makes sense a you know i
postulate a set of primitives and then i
try to use the interaction between those
to account for the phenomena and a
principled manner hopefully can
formalize that Steve Weinberg's point
that he is pointing towards a different
example but you know it's not that we
don't use philosophy it's that we often
just use bad philosophy hit up slightly
better philosophy that's right that's
the kind of stuff flavors don't really
help it's actually is fascinating
because sometimes I mean I don't think I
shared Jerry coins view that this is a
you know a celebration and of
how great philosophy is but you know I
do feel sort of genius like goodbye you
know at the end
so here's a very specific question I can
ask David because I told you how I
thought your work me and I think it has
been taken seriously by some flossers
who work on time consciousness I could
be wrong about that but I wanted to ask
you back you just gave you said it'd be
nice if philosophers could tell you what
a mechanistic explanation is now there's
a group I like the Peter makam er Karl
Craver if they had any influence these
people are the people who claim that
they've got it down and they interact
all the time with cognitive scientists
and cognitive neuroscientists and all
they write about is or bill Bechtel so
you never heard you heard his name so
that's just interesting right because
there is a group of people who claim to
do this very thing and you didn't hear
about them just as you hadn't heard
about Sameera Shaka
no review so this is kind of a just a
feature of the intellectual division of
labor that's right sort of in front of
us right now I was going to comment on
that same problem with the intellectual
division of labor that the gap between
philosophers conversations about for
example causation and the relevant
discussions among the very scientists
that and the a glaring example at the
moment in in my field is there is a very
hot debate methodological debate going
on in economics right now over what you
need to do to try to establish what we
mean by caused by causal hypothesis
which is how you identify the
statistical properties of a data
generating process right we take
ourselves to be doing the kind of
information
well writ large right so not just that
and not just in the narrow sense
um now it's hard these days because
there are two styles that are competing
with each other you know linear estimate
linear estimation using instrumental
variables on the one hand or
identification of structural models on
the other hand it's hard these days to
get through an empirical paper in
economics without somebody getting into
a quarrel over that but the very the
philosophers of economics and the
economic methodologists who are mostly
philosophers so far have been totally
unaware of this right so so their
debates going on about causation and
economics the economists don't recognize
and if never
would not encounter regard as a real
problem The Economist's are having an
argument over how do I think about
causation and the philosophers don't
know it's kind of self turkey
triumphalist philosophy fest um but that
one of the things that really ease or
destruct me when you've sent the list of
questions was these are awful
these are hardcore philosophical
freewill morality you know reality what
else do you have there I mean you know
meaning I mean this is the hardcore
stuff if Fox furs didn't have something
you know a lot to say about this um and
these are all philosophers you take
science very very seriously and try to
absorb as much of you know as the
relevant science as it's possible but
yet have more to say even one would hope
then the scientists you know well
there's just no excuse for a philosophy
departments then I mean it would have to
be it seems to me um you know that the
philosophers would have a lot to say
here the this is hardcore stuff so what
but they spend their entire lives
thinking about yeah I I'm aware of the
time Sean's holding a coffee cup and
waving it at me but I want to let you
reply but you know after this we're all
gonna have a chance to kind of do our
little summaries and crisscross again so
but but do you want to have this just
for a super good question again maybe
because the questions are philosophical
minds I wish I feel someone competent to
address and feeling more in coverage
economist goes on I'm wondering you know
I'll inform that when scientists try to
do philosophy but that's the impression
I get they they generally screw it up
and I'm wondering if there if
philosophers record can think of cases
in which scientists engaging their
philosophy have made a puzzle are you
sure he hates philosophy well you know
there's this poster 12 huh well he said
the one thing I mean it's out of context
I mean does anyone really know that real
this is copy conversation where's my
gavel
oh I'm so conciliatory - Judy a pearl
Einstein look just just since I have the
chair I want to I want to support Alex's
statement shook so I've been thinking a
lot about Einsteins you know special
relativity and in particular he took a
philosophical stance in the beginning by
saying I don't believe anyone should be
special I mean it's a very philosophical
position really and that from there and
the constancy of the speed of light you
know he's willing to throw away the
nature of space-time and that's pretty
enormous like is it fair enough but what
I'm saying is he his philosophy was
front and present in terms of the first
step and moving forward okay one more
goodbye miss doing bad philosophy and
therefore holding back side which is
Ernst Mach in Germany in the later part
of the 1979 he chose not to believe in
advocates for philosophical reasons he
was a scientist but you know he said
well you can't observe an appositive
therefore Bronowski said but God doesn't
killed himself because he thought he'd
lost that debate with mom well you know
what but I'm looking forward to
Rebecca's novel on Boltzmann that's a
sure killing himself is the first line
of my first book but I just just to say
we're allowed to make mistakes though so
let's it's we gotta be careful team bad
philosophy and making a genuine error
you know what I mean example of a
scientist just waiting in thinking that
they can do philosophy butter in a
normative sense it was stupid
you had what cuz in fairness I skipped
over you you wanted to throw one down oh
you're just adorable
okay
you